you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess calm
right now and I just got done going
through several tactics trainer puzzles
and I'm going to share three of them
with you three that I found interesting
in each of these puzzles it's light to
move and so feel free to treat this as a
bit of a pop quiz if you'd like to go
ahead pause the video see if you can
find the best continuation okay the
solution to this first one is to
immediately push and the bishop must try
to track it down in the following way
Bishop a4 we push and then Bishop to d7
if the bishop goes here this will allow
for the tactic Bishop c4 pinning the
bishop to the king and then we will
march on and soon promote so maybe the
best try for black is to meet the move
c6 with Bishop a4 and after c7 Bishop d7
what do we do from here well we try to
flush the bishop off of this diagonal
kicking off with Qing Yi seven Bishop c8
King d8 and now we're to go with the
bishop on Bishop b7 we can kick him off
of the promotion square with Bishop to
g2 Bishop takes Bishop and then we push
through and another option is to play
now Bishop f5 which case we can try to
deflect the bishop once more with Bishop
d3 after Bishop e6 similar to the first
variation we have this idea to now pin
the bishop to the king and we'll next
promote and go ahead and win so I
thought that that one was pretty neat I
worked through about a dozen of them and
I also came across this puzzle here
that's
similarly related I would say Bishop
pending so once more it's white to move
it feel free to pause the video and see
if you can work it out okay
solution here is to first stop the
bishop from getting on the diagonal this
no this one's tricky this is one that
stumped me King to e6 stops Bishop to e6
and you really have to be precise with
this one you'll see what I mean I would
not be surprised if the vast majority of
viewers who took the time out to try and
solve this one got it wrong
so after King to e6 b3 of course we push
the pawn here snow benefit in moving our
King but now what needs to be calculated
is the following after Bishop to e5 of
course take the bishop and after b2 what
do we do here
may be tempting to just promote is there
something better there is something
better than promoting to a queen this is
not the solution
if you promote to a queen black promotes
and after this check which many of you
may have seen the skewer idea notice now
after King to see four on Queen takes
Queen we now would have stalemate that's
what got me
maybe if any of you can relate to that
so what is the winning idea
well you promote to a rook that way on
promotion you can give a check and
doesn't matter if the King ends up here
we take the Queen and this time we're
not covering the key square d3 a very
clever solution feel free to share if
you got that one correct or not yeah
like I said stumped me I just went
straight in thinking you promote to a
queen and pick the queen up but yeah
there's that little stalemate idea with
the king hiding on c4 hmm okay one last
one any of you on your way to going
three for three
alright this is the last one white to
move go ahead pause the video see if you
can find it the best continuation okay
the solution to this one is direct a1
and now what 14 black there's only one
move and now we go ahead and sacrifice
our rook what's the idea behind this
well first off let me just mention if
the King goes to c7 that's me
so king takes rook and when nui now come
over with the other rope what's
important maybe I shouldn't have gone
with this straight away what helped me
in figuring out this was knowing that
black has a serious threat of taking the
knight forcing queen takes bishop and
then giving me here so I knew at the I
knew the moves must be very forceful for
okay one rook e8 what's the idea
rook a one rook e8 again and now we have
Queen a1 so how is this a little bit
different now we're going to now revisit
a eight again not quite here now is the
star move Queen to H to me a seven
sacrificing the third major piece for
what reason well let me just point out
if the King goes to c8 we would now have
Queen a 8 and B 6 mates and the other
move order King c7 we would push first
and then give me with the Queen and
finally King takes Queen is now met with
knight c6 that's a double check King a 8
is the only move and then Knight b6
almost certainly a composition but one
that is masked quite well I know I
didn't I didn't think that it was some
composition but I believe yeah we are
working with the composition in this one
whoever came up with it did a very good
job of making it look like it was from
some type of you know regular game
played like it was a an actual game with
these mate threats bearing down on h2
but yeah I thought that that one was
pretty cool
in the end what it was that that was a
mate in at this moment right here one
two three four five six seven now it was
a mate in eight so a cool group of three
puzzles I think at least feel free to
share how you did with them in the
comment section below and as usual I
hope you enjoyed it that's all for now
take care bye
you
[Music]